Speaker 1: Welcome back to The David Pakman
Show, I am Ferren Cousins sitting in for David
Pakman today, and don't forget, you can follow
me on Twitter.
In fact, on all social media at Ferren Balanced,
you can also get me on YouTube, dotcom, fair
and balanced and the big YouTube channel,
YouTube dotcom slash the ring of fire.
Well, folks, we've done a good job today so
far of not talking about Donald Trump.
So let's talk about Donald Trump right now,
because there has been some some Trump developments
this week.
The first thing I want to talk about here,
there was a piece this week from a good friend
of mine at Salon Dotcom, writer by the name
of Chauncey de Vega, a piece titled Are Trump's
Followers Being Conned?
No, they gave him 100 million because they
love him.
If you have a chance, I encourage everybody.
Go read this piece because I love it.
See, for a long time, many, many years, actually,
I have been saying that Trump is conning his
supporters.
So when I saw this piece, almost felt like,
oh, oh, no, I hope I'm not mentioned in it
because I had mentioned they had be were being
conned even earlier this week when it was
reported that Donald Trump at one hundred
million dollars, 100 million dollars, that
he is definitely not using to help his good
friend Rudy Giuliani.
But that's a story for a different day that
David actually covered earlier this week.
Either way, Trump's got one hundred million
dollars.
He's raising it from all over the country.
People just sending him money, money, money.
He's spending it at his own properties to
a degree.
Hundreds of thousands of dollars have been
spent on his own properties, which he has
100 percent interest in some of the properties
where it's been spent.
So most of it goes right back into his own
pocket.
So my logical conclusion is, yes, these individuals
are being conned because some of this money,
a good chunk of it was raised under the guise
of we're going to use this the Trump PACs,
we're going to use this to pay for ballot
audits, to pay for election challenges.
And they spent a whopping zero dollars on
it.
So they gave Trump money thinking it was going
to one thing and then it didn't go to that.
And I would come to the conclusion logically,
these people are being conned.
But Chauncy to Veiga actually makes a much
better point than I was able to make.
And he says it's not that they're being conned,
sure, they might be being conned, but they
also don't care.
They would still give the money to him regardless.
And there's a great explanation as to why.
See, we found out late last year that the
Trump campaign was essentially and the RNC
did it, I think a little bit, too.
But anyway, they were essentially scamming
their supporters and auto enrolling them in
these monthly donations.
So somebody thought they're giving a one time
donation.
They didn't read the fine print.
They didn't go through all the, you know,
hurdles to turn off the recurring payment.
And so they just kept month after month after
month.
Some people lost, you know, tons and tons
of money for this.
And even after they turned it off, though,
some of them are still giving money to Donald
Trump.
They said, oh, yeah, it was horrible, we got
swindled here, I was going to give him money.
And that's just one example that, you know,
kind of proves the point that they don't care
that they're being conned.
And that's a point that the Veiga really makes
very well in this piece, is that.
Even if the money doesn't go.
Where they think it's going to go.
Even if they're told one thing and a completely
opposite thing happens, they still like him,
they still want him to be the president, they
still support him.
They are still going to give him that money.
Now, I had actually mentioned in a segment
on my channel, Fair and Balanced, earlier
this week that I've run out of sympathy for
these people.
I have no more empathy if they go bankrupt
giving money to Donald Trump.
Sure, I don't want it to happen.
But at this point, they've had enough warnings.
That if it happens, it happens.
Because it's worse than being conned.
And that's kind of the point that the Veiga
makes in the piece, you know, that's that's
the big conclusion here, is that it's worse
than a con.
It's a called.
That's what it is, it doesn't matter what
he does to some of these people, and again,
I'm not saying all Republicans are in the
cold, but you do have this die hard sect of
Trump supporters that it is really difficult
to describe them as anything else because
it doesn't matter what he says, it doesn't
matter what he does.
It doesn't matter if he lies to their face
about it.
Heck, we got reports that he likely didn't
donate the last couple months of his salary
like he promised to always do and his kids
would always boast about on social media.
We also know that GDP growth under Donald
Trump, this another story came out this week.
Was the lowest it's ever been since the Great
Depression.
No president had worse GDP growth and Donald
Trump, George W. Bush came close, his was
one point eight percent over eight years.
Trump's was one point six percent over four
years.
So economically speaking, the guy was really,
really bad.
But the supporters don't care.
They're still clamoring for him, they still
want more from him, they still want him to
be president again, probably holding out hope
that what is this, a week from August 13th
at this point?
Oh, my God.
You know, if Linda's original correction was
correct, your prediction was correct, scuse
me would be a week away from coming back and
these people would love it.
They don't care about the lies.
They don't care about the vulgar behavior.
They don't care about how he mocked a disabled
reporter way back in the day.
They don't care about any of it.
And they don't care what he uses their money
for, they just want to keep giving it to him.
And at this point, those individuals.
It's likely that they can't be pulled out
of this, certainly not by somebody like me.
You know, you would need somebody who actually
understands that kind of cult mentality and
how to actually deprogram people.
Which, yes, there are experts in that, and
those are the ones who really would have to
work on these individuals, but until then,
they're going to keep giving until they can't
give any more.
They know they're being conned.
They just stopped caring